what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to kevin samuels uh
tick-tock compilation
savage moment so before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos all right let's get going
okay
[Music]
[Music]
the women love kevin oh my gosh man's
got game
everyone's arguing a fresh and fit have
game i feel like people should take game
from kevin samuels because the man
clearly
clearly gets it
okay what's next
you were already a mother when you
married him right
right
he accepted your child
he's flattering i'm slapping the [ __ ]
out of you
he accepted joe's child
you didn't give him a child
and you started cheating on him were you
cheating on him with your baby daddy
yeah
you yeah
ladies these are choices i don't care
what
i've been the women when we feel a
certain type of way we make choices
based on how we feel
and the thing about marriage is
you can't make choices about how you
feel
like sometimes you might not
feel the love towards your husband
but
sleeping with your baby daddy that is a
choice also i'm sorry my dog is snoring
if if you can hear that i don't know if
you can smash business
wow
i'm oh man i'm getting that meant that
that's trash man that is some trashy
[ __ ]
that is some trashy [ __ ] it was it was
very tragic
holy crap
she does not even seem sorry oh my gosh
all right
who ended up filing for divorce
me
oh my god
oh my god
when you decide to come back to the
states
are you going to be a student
hit me up and [ __ ] you can't have a man
like me
no
yeah we can't have a man like me
i think i can
but [ __ ]
oh
you ain't fighting up for a man like me
oh my god i have my that's not fair i
have my bonding on no i am okay but even
even let's say if she was
it's like you're that's trashy to come
on alive and wear a bonnet i'm sorry
i hate to say it i would think it's
trashy to wear like
curly like curlers and come on alive
like that
dress in somebody else's head
okay
i told you man i was trying to help you
but you keep going on so i'm like all
right
no i'm letting you help me
that's what i'm here for
no you're trying to what you're doing is
you're avoiding the conversation
yeah i'm just living life i'll never be
too old that's cool crap i have a baby
face yeah black and see see guys you
can't make this [ __ ]
oh
gosh
in your personal relationships with me
have they become
easier yes have they become more
productive yes
where is the proof of that proof of it
is in my peace of mind it's in the
quality of men that i've dated it's also
within my
mental health
oh dear
oh dear proof would be if you had a man
that's the only way to prove that man
maybe it's time to stop because i don't
know why you're cursing at me
i guess i can't get the [ __ ] off my
phone
well it all depends upon the
intellectual dominion of the world and
the transgressions and the
aqua meridians of the bernoulli
equations and if the if was the fifth
then you get down to do the but
do you have a man nope
are you having better personal i have a
better personal relationships yes i
certainly am where's your man don't have
one
damn
damn how can you tell well i feel better
about not having one
oh
did i did i miss that somebody
and that's the thing i think a lot of
times as women we're told you're okay
without a man you don't need a man
when what we're not told is find a man
before you're 35 or you will probably be
depressed and sad for the rest of your
life
damn
no but okay how much do you weigh
2 20. i weigh 210 and i'm six foot four
you broke the first rule see you ladies
don't mind breaking the rules the men
are visual
the men want women that are fit feminine
friendly cooperative submissive i don't
mind being the size of i'm sorry you're
five foot eight
you're about the size of emmitt smith or
barry sanders
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i cannot roast people like that
like i cannot think of stuff fast enough
oh my god you can hit the a-gap like a
[ __ ] oh my god
all right
so don't come in here talk about what me
and should not be able to do when they
gotta accept uh somebody who can run out
the power eye
okay
i mean i'm being silly
i'm being silly because i'm being silly
because
to make
and when i say go back to your ex you
say no no no no no oh man
you made babies with him
okay this is something i do not
understand
ladies if you get pregnant in 2021
almost 2022 it is your own
fault
okay
we have birth control we have the pill
right
we have an iud
okay
on top of that we also have condoms
we also have plan b
and you can track your
ovulation schedule
if if you do all of that and then get
pregnant i'll have some sympathy for you
but i just i got a hard time believing
that we're doing all this like you do
not have to get pregnant
yeah but i was young i feel like that's
not fair
i was very young we all make mistakes
how old
that was pathetic
say that again
i said i feel like that's not fair
because
it's not a mistake because ladies what
are the odds you get pregnant even
people trying to get pregnant
don't usually get pregnant on the first
time
you probably let him finish in you
decent amount of time i'm just saying
and i was young and now i'm older you're
25 years old and you feel like that's
not fair
ma'am you sound like
what
[ __ ] if you want a burger
eat a burger
[Music]
i mean seriously man i feel like it's
not fair
that's not something an adult says
name me the product that gains value
with age and use a product that gains
value with age and use yeah
men right
men
i'm going to say you're mine but i may
be different
i said a product can where can you go
buy a mind a product a product a product
i don't know but i'm pretty sure you're
gonna tell me
uh yeah nothing
wow
nothing
and let's just talk about your cookies
they're getting older and they've been
used
that don't mean nothing
i don't know why as women we ignore the
fact that that does mean something
look it
i don't enjoy it
i wish
that every boyfriend we have didn't you
know count against us
or make us less valuable
[Music]
but [ __ ] it is what it is don't deny the
truth that's what i don't even
understand i was having a conversation
with this guy the other day
and he he was insisting that body count
doesn't matter and i'm like it matters
like
i'm sorry but it does
and
but it's weird because i was having this
argument like with a guy
but
and i'm not and i think where he's
coming from is like guys will hold it
over their girlfriend's head or guys
will like
instead of just saying okay i'm not
gonna date her they'll just like do do
all this extra [ __ ]
but
like i'm not
ever gonna tell someone who they can and
cannot date like who you have sex with
is 100 up to you
and i'm sorry but a lot of guys don't
want a girl that's been with a ton of
guys
yeah but let me know what
you guys think about that in the
comments they don't
oh you are angry
no i'm honest i'm honest man no i'm just
giving you my reality because everybody
else out here i can live in this facade
in this fairytale world
you need to connect your microphone
you need to connect your microphone
lieutenant wharf connection
like adorn in this [ __ ]
oh come on
connect your microphone man connect your
microphone
oh my gosh the funniest part of kevin
samuel show
is
women not being able to figure out basic
technology
like i they should be a com compilation
of just women like not being able to
connect
security detail
oh [ __ ]
oh god
[Music]
hey how are you
hello
hello yes it's connected
and what would you rank yourself
on the open market
i'd say about a seven eight
[Music]
you made babies with him oh no i
accidentally dropped some oh no
oh gosh we were over here i think
is a five
five i'm gonna say it one more time so
what number should i use
the right one which is a five
okay what makes me average because you
look average
because you look at oh my god he is so
blunt going to club you standing in a
long line you don't get in vip
you stand in line with the men
it's not a bad thing i've never been in
a club
with a long line
oh well
oh wait yeah i have oh my gosh i forgot
when i went to that pickup camp you
don't you don't watch
why i mean what's wrong with being
average though
and that's the thing a lot of times as
women like we take that as an insult but
the world
needs average people
i don't know where am i women with low
self-esteem
i've had low self-esteem from a young
age i've never really been confident or
thought that highly of myself i don't
even really like myself most days to be
honest
sorry that was probably a little too
honest to put on camera but it's true
like
i don't understand why these girls would
be like i'm a ted i'm a 10 i'm like i
would never have the nerve to call
myself a 10.
my boyfriend tried to call me a 10 once
and i was like arguing with him i'm like
why are you lying to me like i'm not a
10
but
watching what you go
i ruined things i ruined moments
like you're a tent and like he's trying
to be nice and i just oh my god oh my
god i have the problem
am i married
are you married
i'm gonna ask you one more time and if
not i can beat you good night
also so the narrative is if if if
i'm not are you married
but what does that matter
okay i'll say this much i choose not to
be in a room
i choose not to be married
she said you have a woman issues and i'm
like
look homeboy uh
you're the last person you have problems
with people
do you have people questioning whether
you were naturally born a woman
from one to ten and you can't use seven
face only no hair extensions you're
natural
they're not your face what would you
give yourself
um interesting eight
nope
nope no
[Music]
i
i wish i could see what she looks like
kelly rowland's a nine you give yourself
beyonce
looks beyonce has an a oh my god if
beyonce has an eight then i'm a freaking
two
i'm i'm actually based off what men have
told me they have said i'm a nine you
probably i mean i saw you pop up i saw
you pop up
yeah i just came from the gym so
i look her up uh beauty is beauty
i'm an image consultant
i'm not here to hurt feelings but let's
just not know
a lot of us women agree with you and
we're we're
meeting a person a man that's that's a
leader like you you know and my husband
for instance
i just appreciate everything that you do
and
i just have to tell you that because you
really have helped me in a lot of ways
you know women who genuinely who've
never had a father figure and you come
up and you stand up and you take root
and say no this has to change there's
people that really appreciate that and i
just wanted to tell you how much i
appreciate you and everything that you
do
oh
oh thank you very much i appreciate it
thanks kevin bye-bye have a good night
i have lost 40 pounds listening to you
i have got therapy i moved into a new
city
huh
hey we went to college together yeah how
you doing that's when you get to hey big
head text that's right
that's when they cuz they they know
ain't no man in the future looking for
them so they start looking through the
trash people they pass
holy jesus
i know it
jessica they start looking through the
trash people they pass looking for old
ex-boyfriend well maybe
maybe he'll accept me with 35 40 more
pounds on he'd like to be then he might
like me now and what happens
is you end up just running up your body
count wasting your time because he's
like well why didn't you want to get
with me when he was 23 and fine now
you're 33 and fluffy now you want me no
back then you didn't want me now you're
fat you're all on me
this man's a savage
oh my gosh
i'm going to hell
men not telling you the truth is not
going to make you happier i think
honestly it's the opposite i think may
have been lying
to too long i think i agree with this i
regret this so much i it does not make
women happy if you lie to them because
it may make us happy in the short term
but in the long term we get results that
we don't like by being lied to
so
too many panda bears and too many people
telling you what you want to hear yep i
think
uh all the people that keep calling you
queens and
uh divas and also all the people that
keep doing this
got no men to put you in front of
period because men
are logical
and men are not going to pay a higher
price
that they can honestly say i'm not going
to pay above average price for average
men just won't do it so ladies two
tracks women are massively unhappy today
by women's estimation of men's
estimation and i think at the core of
one of this is because we have taken
away rankings
hmm
i agree because i would give people
different dating advice based on how
they rank like i would give an eight
nine or ten absolutely different dating
advice and i would give a five six or
seven
actually a seven i would i would maybe
put her in the top but you guys see what
i'm saying like i feel like it depends
on how you look
and
you know your situation with kids
like i think asking a guy to wait for
sex before you have kids
and a high body count is completely
different than asking a guy to wait when
you already
like had a kid with somebody
i don't have to give it to any of these
broke little snotty nose crumb looking
children but you have fun with that
[ __ ] the same man for the rest of
your life while you're in your prime
you're not single by choice
your choices have made you single but
you're not single by choice
why do we know you're not single by
choice because you keep dragging
yourself over here to argue in these
comments sections does anybody know a
mid-30s
attractive
i'm single by choice woman who's happy
plus no i mean i know people that are
happy but i don't know girls that like
if they had it their way
they could like i think they would
prefer to be married with a husband to
be around
a joy
go ahead raise your hands high
beyonce isn't eight kelly rollins or
nine oh my god this lady is not she is
not about to do this
can you put yourself there no oh yeah
absolutely oh my god
i give her a five
i want to say maybe a six when she's
smiling but five
um
are you an eight or nine
we should be getting eight or nine
outcomes i should be getting eight or
nine outcomes yeah you're a flight
attendant right
yes
right so that means you you interface
with men
uh nationwide
yeah
uh if you're an eight or nine someone
would have taken you off a plane by now
put a ring on your finger
okay
i'll give you a six
oh all right
you're cute
but you're not pretty beautiful okay
well this one i don't understand kevin's
rankings she's cute right but sweetie is
way hotter than her and he gives sweetie
a six
like sweetie
come on
four gorgeous i give you a six that's
not an insult man you're cute
oh no i don't take it as an insult the
lineup with kelly rowland and beyonce
and i just put him in front of a
thousand american men
they say yep these women are all similar
oh yeah
i think so
you don't feel like you need god in the
marriage no no i just want to be clear
so when i started going in on christian
marriage you don't start
going sideways oh my gosh i had
we're gonna talk about religion i had
these thoughts when i was younger i
remember thinking like these women would
tell us to be abstinent and i was like
none of you guys were
like i remember thinking like
yeah you'll be like
i specifically remember this christian
speaker coming to our our college or our
high school because i went to catholic
school and her being basically tell tell
us that she like got ran through
and then met her husband
and i i remember thinking like
so you're gonna tell us to wait but you
did whatever you want and still got a
husband like
i don't know i just feel like that's the
best and that's the point
you don't know
eve's job was to be to help me
that's your job your role on the planet
is amazing not your career not your job
take it up with your god
you don't like it
no no no no no
first of all understand something
um
over here over here we stay on the
subject the men you decide to let your
better your problems
then where's your husband i'm picky i
have a problem like
but i'm very picky
oh my god
kevin samuels is literally an absolute
savage
um i thought that that clip those clips
really show the state of like modern
women today because
and when i say modern women i don't mean
like women in 2021 i mean like
i want to choose my words carefully i
mean women that
are really
how do i put it
oh my gosh basically have let like the
world and the ideologies of like worldly
things get to them so
they're told they're queens be confident
do whatever you want like you can do no
wrong and they really buy into that like
were none of you bullied
i
i don't want to be that person but
bullying helped me as a person
being told you i was not good enough
made me try harder to be good enough now
am i a little bit too much with people
pleasers sure sure but like guys bully
each other just a little
not a lot but let me know in the
comments if you guys agree or disagree
don't forget to subscribe ring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time